ange acte entendu parler du blind test
de lunettes noires pour nuits blanches
moi j'ai eu du mal toute ma vie à
distinguer la guitare du trombone ouais
mais là on va te demander si le
reconnaître des musiques de puces donc
ça va quand même peut-être un peu plus
bon alors qu retire à l'avant
ah ça commence res passer un peuple
auj
non c'est pas dans le bio avec 4 et donc
non c'est pas un café alors je vais
t'aider
c'est un les emplois oui oui rigide et
c'est parti tu trouves pas ça fais
attention tu là bas alors maurice lévy
au téléphone demain matin je sors du
café peut être établie
à pons
c'est ça non
puis là
c'est moins que non non on ne souffle
pas tout le monde connaît sa mémoire et
oui la bière à la bière l'agréal de
bière la bière et annabelle nord on
attend la bière et nick et moi non mais
les choses n'ont fait ni chaud with
aguicher sur cd chaussures c'est pas
bâtard non-cash que les prévenus à la
barre c'est pas andré engraisser en la
toile nous va bien vrai il restera non
il reste encore des marques de
chaussures de sport c'est pas dans le
palais comme sportif
et
mais je n'écris manipuler pub adidas en
syldavie date apprend autant mettre une
facile en attendant merci la télé alors
là si tu trouve face à face à ces graves
je te signale tout de suite mais qu'est
ce que tu fais quand ils veulent aller
festival de pub tu te fais bronze et
j'ai fait du ski le temps d'attendre
c'est à café nord
c'est un soft drinks
c'est chouette
si gary savage doucement mais qui a
évolué bordas
c'est en plus c'est une chanson qui est
monté au hit parade en pas au top 50 des
voix a tancé pts et c'est celui qui
n'est pas danone d'adaltis appétit seul
qui ait pas d'annoncé l'autre chez payot
plaie non je suis vidé entre danone et
yoplait l'asie d'asie cobayes s'appelle
c'est pas germé au nord
un appel à sa mémoire
c'est pas chez toi t'es sur elle elle ne
s'est pas tu reconnais pas de l'allumer
sécher le pito je connais la journée je
paye racheté depuis par htc
comment s'appelle ce yaourt bien mon
chat au chant bourse
waouh
n'avez vous pas à ça j'ai peur que ce
soit chez nous
tu vas perdre le budget ça les tories
fletcher engueuler par les associés et
pas douceur droit non c'est pas carte
loi non ce n'est pas du temps perdu le
budget non c'est un café mais lequel
ces pannes ha non il va tous faire les
herbes mais ça prouve que je connais
bien les marques
je n'ai pas les mots c'est pas la maison
du café nord on va les gars fait pas
grand mère non plus lors il encore et
j'aimerais assez le générique de chaque
vabre va chez toi ça je m'assume un don
est une filiale à twilight est là
le racheter l'émission je veux faire
quelque chose
c'est fini pour lui de kpiweb quand même
arriver là et comme légal à paris
toujours guy jeannard dix ans il doit
quoi l'art donc je me déguise un arbitre
a lancé les lunettes noires pour tous
les gagnants ah bon parce qu'ils gagnent
et là non